i was like you know i feel very
disconnected from the world first of all
and now my my
person and uh and i just dug in writing
nick jonas is why priyanka chopra
inspired his new music
okay well priyanka and her absence
inspired his new music
how did you know that your fiance was
the one
uh it was kind of an instant thing knew
once we locked in together that i had a
partner for life and a teammate somebody
can
walk to the good times and bad times
with and that was that was
the key i'm blushing now the 28 year old
singer appeared on tuesday's episode of
the tonight show starring jimmy fallon
and he opened up about his upcoming
album spaceman
and how the past year of quarantine amid
the pandemic
influenced his music i sort of started
writing this record back in july
my wife was was over in germany
finishing up this little movie called
the matrix and and i was like you know i
feel
very disconnected from the world first
of all and now my my
person and uh and i just dug in writing
with uh greg kirsten and mozella and
within a couple days i was like oh this
is this is
a solo album then a few days later i was
like this is a
kind of like themed album the theme of
nick's new music is
all about the isolation many people have
felt over the last year
this year of being sort of disconnected
from reality disconnected from the world
and feeling like we're on our own planet
and
um and you know also obviously missing
her at that time as well and then
reconnecting with her and then the main
theme from this album i think is
more than anything it's just about
hopefulness for the future and
seeing a brighter day ahead and during a
recent chat with apple music's zane lowe
nick explained how his new tunes are
dedicated to his leading lady
he says most of the songs are quote love
letters to priyanka
i'm grateful to have that because it
makes her happy and that's
most important my life is very good
right now very excited lots of good
things coming up
and since their work sometimes keeps
them apart nick
previously told et that his favorite
part of quarantine was getting to spend
so much time with his wife then the
biggest upside of all this has
been that time at home which uh me and
priya wouldn't have had
you know had this all happened as busy
as our schedules have been in the last
couple years
so you know that has been an upside
you